now governments and businesses around
the world are promising to cut their
carbon emissions to help limit global
warming around 90 percent of the global
economy is now covered by some kind of
net zero target but how good
are these commitments let's put it to
our panel james that statistic in itself
90
sounds pretty remarkable when you think
where we were uh just a few years ago
but how credible are those commitments
the level of credibility varies
massively but the general direction of
travel is hugely encouraging i mean if
you think back sort of five years ago
six years ago when the paris agreement
was uh signed the most ambitious target
in the world was probably the uk's which
was an 80 cutting emissions by 2050 and
now we've got a situation where 90
percent of the global economy is covered
by these net zero goals the stated
intent of governments that are
responsible for 90 of the global economy
is to effectively fully decarbonize
and where they can't fully decarbonize
expand carbon sinks to compensate um all
activity you've also got 4 000
businesses
or government organizations or city
states or the like but 4 000 different
entities similarly have these net zero
targets in place
the companies involved
command revenues of nearly 20 trillion
dollars this is like the big global
economic project of the age it's the
defining long-term priority of
governments and businesses all around
the world so there's very legitimate
questions about the credibility of some
of these targets they vary massively in
quality some are really good and are
backed by billion dollar investment
plans and are looking at using new
technologies to really deliver deep
decarbonization others are literally
nothing more than a pledge a promise
that we will do this in the future
and some are probably being used to
cover up activity that you wouldn't want
to see but
there is real progress here and having
the target is absolutely the first step
to then delivering on it
judy greta tumber's warned about net
zero targets being used as excuses to
postpone
real action how do you guard against
greenwashing
well rules and so on are being put in
but really it's very difficult because
people first of all set up their targets
and then they list their offsets and
claim that they will actually compensate
for it the real issue is whether we are
actually putting out emissions at all
because offsets may or may not deliver
and once you release any emission that
is into the atmosphere it will stay
there for 300 to 1000 years so that the
offsets and so on actually failing is an
enormous risk to us and other events add
to the overall picture for the first
time we've seen million acre fires as a
result of climate change burning down
massive old growth forests in the usa
while we're blithely talking about
planting trees were upsetting
james i want one final thought from you
when we talk about net zero it's part of
the common language around climate
action now but how many people genuinely
understand what it means and actually
does that matter
um i think that the level of
understanding from the polling is
actually much better than you'd expect
because it is a slightly technical term
you know it does refer to balancing out
the emissions that we have and the
emissions that we soak up and there's a
degree of science behind that um but you
know polling by the uk government has
shown a majority of people are aware of
the term they broadly understand that it
means you know getting to zero emissions
the deep decarbonization
of our economy and and yes and it's
being widely used it's been widely used
in a lot of businesses it's being widely
used by politicians and i think it will
continue to grow in awareness because as
i say is the defining economic priority
that we want to see
and just on the fact that there are
these concerns about offsets and the
like the thing is the vast majority of
advocates for net zero they know that um
you know the un secretary general stood
up at cop26 and said he wants a new
working group to ensure that these
targets are credibly met
there are initiatives that are saying if
you want to say you're net zero you need
to cut your direct emissions by over 90
you can only use compensation or offsets
for the tiny little bit at the end that
is really difficult to tackle so
there are legitimate concerns and we do
need to be wary to spot greenwash but
there is as i say real progress here and
and some some modest source for optimism
given the scale of the challenge that we
face